hello my name's David Haws and in my
previous presentation I explained to you
how crackling was invented and has
contributed substantially to these field
of structural biology and now I'd like
to give you an example of an actual
benefit that was derived from that which
is the HIV epidemic and some of the
drugs that were developed through
structural biology
once again we need to thank Max Perutz
who began the field of structural
biology and at the great vision that
three-dimensional structures not only
permit the identification of how the
molecules act in living organisms but in
fact how the structures can be
determined as well as how drugs can now
be designed using the process called
structure based drug design so now I'd
like to tell you a story of how I have
experienced science for the benefit of
humanity while I was at the Cold Spring
Harbor Laboratory I was told that my
cryocooler
experiments and publications probably
advanced structural biology by 10 or 20
years and at the time you know 10 or 20
years ago scientific discoveries really
usually not a big deal and it didn't
have any significance to me until while
I was preparing for a presentation this
last April at the Protein Data Bank in
Rutgers they asked me to talk about
exactly what I'm telling you
the invention of coral crystallography
and while I was doing that I discovered
the AIDS epidemic and the Lazarus effect
and for those of you who don't know what
the Lazarus effect is in medicine as
disinfectants when many people are dying
and then some event occurs or where
these vast numbers of people stopped
dying and that's exactly what happened
with the AIDS epidemic in 1996
this diagram here is from the United
States statistics from the CDC but let
me just tell you first about the
worldwide AIDS epidemic which began in
1980 there have been 76 million people
who have been infected with HIV virus
since 1980 of whom 39 million have died
and today worldwide there were 37
million people still infected
there was no cure for AIDS as you know
but though there is a therapeutic
treatment and that's what I'm going to
explain so now if I can talk about the
United States this is the death curve
and the infection curve the red ones the
infection occur for AIDS in the United
States so far since 1980 700,000
Americans have died from AIDS and as you
see the curve begins in 1918 continual
increases with hundreds of thousands of
individuals becoming infected with a
with HIV virus each year since the
average lifetime if you had caught HIV
and then during the 80s is typically 2
to 4 years your statistics would move
from the red curve to the blue curve
which is the death rate in about two
years and you see that the death rate is
continuous from 1980 to 1996 it's a
straight line basically which means that
none of the drugs and there were many
drugs that were tried produced any
effect on the death rate in 1984 the HIV
virus was identified as being the causal
agent of HIV and then in 1986 proteins
were isolated one of which is this
protein which is HIV protease and one of
the enzymes that makes HIV virus the
crystal structure was actually
determined the three-dimensional
structure in 1989 and we can thank Merck
laboratory in New Jersey for not only
solved
structure but they published the data to
the whole world in the protein data bank
in 1989 this gave the opportunity for
hundreds of other laboratories to work
on the HIV protease it turned out that
inhibitors were actually made and they
were made using structural biology using
cryocooler
and in 1996 the therapy was introduced
it was this cocktail of three three
drugs which the HIV protease inhibitor
was the most important and instead of
dying you would you would live a normal
life with in fact it was called a
manageable disease and because of that
the individuals did not transfer to the
death curve and you see this precipitous
fall in the death curve in 1996 the
death rate fell from 96 percent down to
below 20 percent so you can just imagine
between 1980 and 1996 if you had become
infected with HIV and you went to your
physician and he would tell you you had
a four percent chance of surviving but
in 1996 you would go in to go to your
doctor and he would say yes sir today
there's a therapy he will not be cured
of HIV but you will in fact become a
manageable disease and this dramatic
fall in the death rate in 1996 is called
the Lazarus effect tens if not hundreds
of thousands of Americans who would not
live and basically the HIV protease
inhibitors of drugs which were developed
were developed years and years faster
than they would have been if there had
not been structural biology and as it
turns out cryocooler which participated
in that so it makes me feel very good
that literally my research done 50 years
ago not ending up in dusty pages in a
journal
actually saving thousands of life that
really is science for the benefit of
humanity experiments that you do
publications that you make as a young
scientist in fact could contribute very
much to the future so I hope you've
become a little bit inspired with the
work that I have done and in fact it
expired me and maybe it'll inspire you
to continue thank you
you